we have breaking news about that deadly
mass shooting in a Southern California
Bar & Country music venue the Ventura
County Sheriff says a gunman opened fire
inside as it was crowded with more than
a hundred people many of them college
students
he killed 12 people including a sheriff
sergeant who was responding to the scene
police found the shooter dead inside and
they reportedly have identified him he's
believed to be 29 years old but his
identity has not yet been released the
rampage took place at the borderline Bar
and Grill that's in Thousand Oaks about
40 miles northwest of Los Angeles
authorities still do not have a motive
for the shooting Carter Evans is near
the scene in Thousand Oaks Carter good
morning to you what's the latest well
police and sheriff's investigators have
just identified the shooter they say he
is 28 year old I am lon he lives in
Newberry Park
not too far from here just a few minutes
away and police say they've had a few
run-ins with him before but nothing
serious
witnesses say the shooter entered when
everybody was having a good time last
night dancing on the dance floor he
stormed through the door and opened fire
police with guns drawn swarmed a bar in
Thousand Oaks California just before
midnight Wednesday as people bloody and
hurt ran for their lives
everyone was hanging out all of a sudden
we heard a bunch of shots
[Applause]
witnesses say the gunman shot the
bouncer at the front door and then fired
multiple rounds inside the borderline
bar and grill reloading and setting off
smoke bombs it's a horrific scene in
there Ben Campbell said he was dancing
when he heard the gunshots and
immediately hit the ground windows broke
the window who are the last people I see
anybody at City guns
nice ran once safely outside those who
were uninjured hugged and cried and
traumatised and worried about the others
still inside it doesn't matter what
community are in it doesn't matter how
safe your community is it can happen
anywhere I just started hearing these
big pops pop pop pop John was inside the
bar near the front door with his stepdad
he said they watched the gunman shoot
the bouncer and then move through the
bar I ran out the front door I hear
chairs being thrown out the window
people were trying to go out the window
and the gunman went to the he went
behind the cash register he kept there
was probably 12 shots before I go out
the front door and he reload amenities
tim is John stepdad he said he regrets
not staying in the bar to help other
victims just have a great time
this maniac came in and started shooting
more now about the shooter 28 year old
ayan long investigators say he is a
former Marine they are trying to
determine a motive for this crime but
there still is none at least just yet
he lives not far from here in a town
called Newberry Park and police are at
his home right now they were able to
identify him with evidence at the scene
we understand by the way according to
FBI data Thousand Oaks where we are
right now is considered the third safest
city in the country Carter thank you